[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's brief video i just want to
quickly go over the short fantastic
beast 3 the secrets of dumbledore teaser
trailer that came out today
inside of the same trailer it was
announced that the full trailer will be
coming out on monday so i'll cover that
as well when we get there
in the meantime let's dive into the
teaser and unpack what we see in the
short 35 seconds we're given
first things first we're showing
familiar territory hogwarts this makes
sense given that at the end of the last
film the good guys were grouped together
the famous wizarding school
next we see newt jacob theseus and
hogwarts professor yulali lally hicks
seeing yulali hicks here is a surprise
as she wasn't given much screen time in
the second film however it has since
been revealed that hicks's true glory is
revealed in fantastic beasts 3 so i'm
excited for that the group are walking
down the hogwarts corridor towards none
other than albus dumbledore who appears
to be standing in front of some kind of
portal pillar with ancient looking
markings inside what looks to be the
room of requirement the group then get
transported through the portal one by
one in the next frame we're shown a huge
mountain with a massive set of stairs
and what appears to be celebratory
fireworks going off i could be way off
here but from the way that the buildings
look and judging by the fact that we're
looking at a mountain i think it could
potentially be the japanese wizarding
school mahutukuro which is located on
the topmost point of the volcanic island
of manami iwo jima the fireworks also
appear to be creating a kind of emblem
in the sky which matches the school's
logo next we're shown maz aka
grindelwald being mobbed by massive
groups of people however they all seem
to appear to be quite happy with him and
he even looks quite pleased with himself
after this we're given a bunch of quick
cuts we see vinda rosier one of
grindelwald's acolytes shooting what
appears to be the killing curse we see
newt running through a forest we see an
unidentifiable figure flying a broom on
the hogwarts grounds we see theseus what
appears to be some kind of danger and
next we see something huge we see none
other than jacob holding a wand whose
wand is it i'm not sure
but this could mean something huge
perhaps jacob is a squib and not just a
nomad or muggle as we previously thought
in the next frame we see dumbledore with
an homage to the harry potter films the
golden snitch and in the following frame
we're shown something truly terrifying
credence bare bone hair grown out
completely wreaking havoc and causing
all sorts of destruction
and who you might ask is standing in
front of him why albus dumbledore of
course could this mean a jewel of epic
proportions could this mean credence is
corrupted in the last frame we see
dumbledore speaking to an unidentifiable
figure saying the following even when
every instinct tells you not to who is
this mysterious man he's speaking to
here looks like it could maybe be
theseus what do you guys think give any
extra tidbits you'd like to share that
you noticed in the teaser comment down
below until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
[Music]
you